yo bootleg cat podcast man shout out to
my guy Nick Grant in the building yes
sir new album is dropping on September
22nd which is what two weeks two and a
half weeks three weeks yeah I don't even
know bro I'm like we're still in August
kind of right
right it's August 31st by the time
you're watching this it'll probably be
like closer to the album date uh
September 22nd Sunday dinner yes sir
you've been dropping like episodes to
kind of push the like Narrative of what
the album is exactly like a short film
just you know everybody got the story of
like going making it out and then going
back home and you know having a hard
time with the family or just friends
right just grew up with just people
around in the neighborhood how many
episodes you do like 18 19 yeah I did
like 18 19. yeah yeah that's a lot yeah
that's a lot that's a lot we shot we
shot it in like a week we like that's
important though for you like obviously
you said you told me off off the uh area
this is your most personal albums yeah
yeah for sure 100 million percent my
most personal album it just kind of
talks about like you know me growing up
in my neighborhood and um you know my
family having addiction issues and me
having a move with my grandma and um one
of her requirements was like you know
just have your ass at church every
Sunday and just go to school do what you
got to do and um
you know that's pretty much everybody's
requirement every Sunday just go to
church right and as as they're coming in
and out of the house
um I'm picking up what I want to be from
different people and what I don't want
to be so it's whether whether it's like
the drug dealing customer you could go
either way yeah for sure for sure that
stay fresh but I'm just taking like what
I feel like are the best things or that
I relate to the motion you know just
kind of adding them to who I am uh fully
independent now yeah yeah that's good
man because I know you were epic and
then you had a little I don't know if
people know if you were somewhere else
for a sec yeah yeah
you're independent now yeah
um so go support the album Sunday dinner
uh catch the fade is the record I just
catch this way yeah you've been doing
your research I appreciate it yeah I
just heard the record who is that you on
the hook yes me and my uh my homegirl
her name is rakaya super talented super
dope right yeah appreciate you man thank
you yeah that's like a I feel like more
people should approach life with hey
let's fight let's not shoot absolutely
yeah for sure for sure I get man that's
how I came up like that was the easiest
way to solve it if you couldn't get past
the conversation and then it was easier
to have a conversation after that 100 so
it's like that's the I feel like it's
not the best way to handle it but it's
better it's better than yeah for sure
I mean 100 and you're from the south so
yeah everybody's strapped for real open
carry though
for real well look man go support the
album it's out the singles out right now
tons of content out you can go watch uh
and of course we're just gonna have my
guys one of the best so man thank you
you came through with some bars
ah I'm off the hook and I get the page
when life gave us lemons look how many
men it made different toilet I got [__]
for days you playing file imma send the
wave nothing like getting paid man I'm
just waiting for the day I hear rapper
just me you searching for a problem imma
clear your history the higher that I
climb the more you resent me even my
engineer said you [__] mixy I'm back
around like when [__] pillow talking
strangers from where they keep a stick
like they switching Gamers you pull
around here better keep your Banger they
wish your [__] would slide boy they
playing Jenga black drop like a Harlem
Renaissance painting God's flow [__] I
just want my red and Sheamus [__] do
anything just to be famous my Keen Eye
got me low down dirty shaming real [__]
I'm cold I'm still sick my flow Nitro
bet she blow me real quick Kaboom make
room for the champion [__] if they sleep
let them sleep here's an Ambien never
trust These Hoes Got the game from my
auntie them label me a hater cause I'm
not a fan of them man don't judge me
judge they pin game I'm winning only
streaks you had with [__] stains kiss
Rings courtesy of a dawn I'm the one get
you gone Heaven ain't hard to find just
listen to this rhyme don't come in
you're not allowed running [__] by a
mile hunt it's about a Powers lovely
when I retire gather too many stripes
for [__] to play me foul it's a
shootout in the ghetto my grannies they
play inside fourth grade education These
[__] Gonna wave the nine getting
stronger woons them chicks and raising
pies showered in the truth While others
they bathe in lies where you get your
Style from don't know it may be mine if
I help you you don't owe me just make a
way to shine stay away from bad vibes I
just made my way to God uh that boy
nasty like a dirty foot home uh you big
[__] like a 30-foot Hole uh I know my
worth if I was nervous before you wack
[__] getting curved in the dough you
[__] need to get out real [__] in
this [__] [__] be advised money on
your head they pay you no never mind
Dead Presidents my pockets on CSI I'm
blind to your dog and ain't nobody
seeing I just know you can't buy cool
you can't teach a Vibe murder explodes
you know I leave no beat alive these
[__] snitching Undercovers where's the
better lies they make you move your
whole fam like electric slide my class
threw it off cause I'm a ghetto guy five
six but when she said she's seven five
uh when you make it they get jealous huh
Splash a [__] tomato cause I ain't
dressing huh she bending over in the
mirror like you see it babe she bout to
get this hard rock I need a VMA cream
seats in the bins look like Lisa Raye
just a Slave to the Rhythm as a freedom
Chase don't make me kill your goat
that's a Peter case
so ahead of my time what you see is late
from where they whip it up quicker than
the Easy Bake from where the skinny
[__] died just from losing weight turn
you to sanitation when they reaching for
the waste no [__] moving Curtis blow
but [__] these the bricks God gave me
the light I gotta lead the way God gave
me the life
[Music]
September 22nd go pre-order it too on
iTunes so when it drops it's on that
chart yes sir spend that money on that
yes sir absolutely absolutely there it
is thank you man I appreciate you thank
you I appreciate you guys watching this
freestyle we got another one coming and
then another one and then another one
and they're all brought to you by our
good Folks at LRG clothing you already
know what it is LRG been keeping you fly
for years they got so much new fly gear
right now
l-r-g.com promo code bootleg when you
check out you'll save 30 off
l-r-g.com another freestyle is on the
way presented by LRG